ce véritablement par milliers qui
arrivent chaque jour les réfugiés cure
transportés en camion après le passage
de la frontière
ils sont installés dans des camps
remarquablement organisée par les
autorités doc est à peine sont-ils
descendu de ces camions qui se
précipitent vers les journalistes pour
témoigner de ce qu'ils viennent de subir
le père de cette petite fille par
exemple nous raconte que son enfant
s'était enfui lors des bombardements
elle a dormi une nuit dans la forêt et
le lendemain elle avait perdu ses
cheveux
là où sa tête touché le sol pendant son
sommeil comme si la terre avait été
imprégné par des substances chimiques
c'est autre paire n'a plus que son
dernier enfant lui était à l'écart du
village son bébé dans une autre famille
et lorsqu'il l'a retrouvé il a découvert
que la peau de l'enfant était couverte
de pierres rouges et que ses yeux
étaient boursouflé à la colère succèdent
l'abattement et simplement les familles
se regroupent autour de nous sans un mot
nous montrent leurs enfants tous ont les
yeux rougis et la peau du visage et
marqués de taches brunes comme s'il
s'était trop approché d'un feu
de nombreux enfants ont également la pop
couvert de pustules et souffrent de
démangeaisons incessantes l'autre ont de
graves problèmes intestinaux de brusque
accès de fièvre sur la réalité de
l'emploi d'armes chimiques les médecins
turcs sont extrêmement prudents il est
vrai qu'il ya aussi un problème
politique entre la turquie et l'irak
mais tous les médecins que nous avons
interrogés sont tous d'accord pour dire
que les infections de pau constater ici
peuvent être d'origine chimique
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas me prononcer
définitivement
il faut faire des analyses et nous
allons faire sur des prélèvements
beaucoup à ce moment là que nous saurons
la vérité le moment nous n'avons que des
hypothèses mais vraiment tout est
possible
sans accepter d'être enregistré d'autres
médecins nous ont dit que la difficulté
provenait du fait qu'il y a deux types
de gaz ce qui bloque la respiration et
atteignent le cerveau provoquant une
mort immédiate et ce qui entraîne des
brûlures dont on ne peut survivre que si
l'on est légèrement atteints pour cette
raison
s'il ya ici des blessés par armes
chimiques ce ne peut être que des
blessés très légers